le chaos en chine pékin la capitale
quasiment guerre la france décide de
rapatrier la plupart de ses
ressortissants exclusivité antenne de
henry kissinger l'ancien secrétaire
d'état américain se dit pessimiste sur
l'évolution des événements chili le bac
pour 400 mille et quelques jeunes
c'était ce matin l'épreuve de philo la
réflexion a été rejointe par l'actualité
chambas les villans d'air car ce sera
une demi-finale chante chesnau coop
beaucoup de surprises encore bonsoir
c'est toute une partie de notre monde
qui est au bord du chaos
en 24 heures la chine a basculé de
l'insurrection étudiante à ce qu'on peut
désormais appeler une guerre civile
combat nous y faire entre eux fuite
éperdue des étrangers pékin en guerre
lui aussi la province en révolte
et pendant ce temps là les dirigeants
chinois restent invisibles
alors bien sûr il est très difficile de
savoir ce qui se passe réellement dans
ce pays immense mais grâce aux images
exceptionnelles que nous avons reçus ce
soir on peut tenter de reconstituer ce
qui s'est passé depuis le week-end
dernier et l'on peut mesurer l'effrayant
de gravité de la situation
jérôme baugnies un convoi de l'armée en
feu au coeur de pékin
image diffusée aujourd'hui par la
télévision chinoise les tournées le
week-end dernier quand deng xiaoping a
décidé d'envoyer les chars écraser le
peuple de pékin propagande contre les
étudiants
d'être des voyous l'épreuve en fait de
la combativité des tessinois armés de
simples cocktails molotov
aujourd'hui la place tiananmen théâtre
du soulèvement pour la démocratie est
devenue un véritable camp retranché
nettoyer ou la statue pour la liberté
érigée par les étudiants a fait place à
des caisses de munitions
l'espoir est revenu pendant quelques
instants
lorsque la division qui occupait cette
place et parapher applaudissements
incrédule bientôt interrompu par des
tirs de kalachnikov en l'air pour
dissuader mais aussi encore une fois
pour tuer
relève par des troupes fraîches comme à
la parade
comme pour prouver que l'ordre militaire
fresnes pourtant des tirs d'artillerie
ont retenti toute la journée selon des
témoins chinois la 27ème armée occupante
pékin affronterez la 38e à une vingtaine
de kilomètres de la capitale
les autorités chinoises semblent avoir
décidé de vider pékin de ces étrangers
témoin de plus en plus gênant alors que
se précise le risque de guerre civile
le quartier de yann jouannel en rouge
sur cette carte où vivent la plupart des
étrangers a été mitraillé par un convoi
militaire
les habitants ont dû se réfugier dans
des hôtels ou des ambassades à shanghai
si les plusieurs tués alors qu'ils
essayaient d'arrêter un train auxquels
la foule à me lever
c'est toute la chine se voir liste en
bleu s'embrase et en 24 heures je vous
le disais la situation semble avoir
basculé avec nous en direct comme chaque
soir notre envoyé spécial à pékin bruno
le dre bonsoir bruno j'ai l'impression
que pour vous aussi journaliste en 24
heures la situation est brusquement
devenu beaucoup plus difficile la
situation et il en est l'état que ab
klein en tous les cas
désormais la loi martiale décrétée par
le premier ministre lee belle isle il y
avait en plus d'une semaine est
appliquée alors cette fois prévoyez tout
d'abord que devait occuper la planète
c'est que c'est bien simple il ne reste
plus que l'armée chinoise sur place et
billy cette fois prévoyez aussi
théoriquement que les journalistes
n'avaient pas le droit de parler des
événements actuels
on imaginait bien sûr que notre travail
est plus difficile
on a même l'impression aujourd'hui à
pékin d'être entré dans une étape de
normalisation la 7éme art mais qui
entrait dans les canettes soient jour et
dans son emprise sur la ville
aujourd'hui on vit au cours de nos
pérégrinations dans la ville avec les
épisodes en tête avec plus de caresses
rencontré à plusieurs reprises des
soldats là jusqu'à maintenant il n'y en
avait pas et ce soir par exemple c'est
bien groupe d'une dizaine d'hommes
baïonnette au canon qui passait devant
l'hôtel nous nous trouvons et encore les
halls de la manne de la 27éme armées de
ne se déplacer qu'en blasé comme s'il
craignait ce de création de la
population être attaqués par la
population
aujourd'hui il semble pouvoir se
déplacer tranquillement dans la ville et
il contrôlait un exemple le
démantèlement des dernières baritel dans
les grands carrefours de beckham en
dehors de vos inscrire vous faites en
ville des sorties vous pouvez faire
est-ce que vous disposez de sources
d'information officielle par exemple
venant de pouvoir répéter les sources
d'information sont la lecture des
journaux la télévision et la radio
chinoise
il faut décoder c'est depuis toujours la
télévision des images que vous venez de
voir ça en devenait vient de commenter
les images soigneusement sélectionnés
pour expliquer que c'est l'armée qui a
été à la clé mais parfois certaines de
ces images nous donnent d'autres
informations
ainsi ce soir en hiver reportage sur la
population qui est d'ailleurs toujours
qualifié de bandit révolutionnaire un
reportage qui met la population mettre
le feu à déplacer les actions qui date
de dimanche alors qu'il apparaît bien
évidemment sur ces images collées que ce
sont des soldats qui ont abandonné
cinquantaine de transports de troupes
blindés
alors s'il qu'ils avaient en face d'eux
des hommes simplement de bâtons et de
pierres alors combien il s'agit d'une
provocation ou bien et je pense je
penserai personnellement pour la seconde
solution
cela veut dire que certaines troupes ont
refusé d' écraser les étudiants et ont
simplement abandonné leur matériel
lorsqu'ils font tomber sur les sur les
premiers barrages dernière question
bruno quand vos circuler en ville est ce
que vous sentez plus menacé maintenant
eh bien il est vrai que le gouvernement
chinois fait savoir aux différents
grands matches désormais l'armée
chinoise tirer à vue sur toute personne
en train de prendre des photos de
l'année dans une situation comme celle
ci est tout même cours des trois
derniers jours
au moins 2000 morts il est toujours
dangereux de travailler
j'ai personnellement l'impression que le
gouvernement chinois sont annualisés
réalité le pays moins deux témoignages
qui se sont connus à l'étranger
bon courage brenot à toute l'équipe
d'antenne 2 et merci de nous tenir au
courant de cette manière est d'ailleurs
l'essence et comment se l'est dit tout à
l'heure à revenir de chine ce matin un
avion est arrivé c'est de pékin au brier
de l'air a pu recueillir quelques
témoignages
écoutez les on a vu des sens d'une
compagnie qui tiraient en l'air et sa
crête est très fort et dans tous les
sens et idiot l'est ont dégagé il ya des
temples qui tirait à peu près sur tout
ce qui vient ce qui bougeait enfin vers
la place oui parce que je n'étais mines
en pl
faisait pas de quartier fait des
consommations 1 c'est clair qu'on
s'était allumé par les temps que la
sortie de l'hôtel de pékin ils tiraient
sur tout ce qui bougeait ils tiraient
sur les gens qui avaient des appareils
de photos des qui voyez un truc qui
brille est une fenêtre et iraient ils
tirent en l'air c'était
c'était n'importe quoi c'est laid mais
c'est sûrement la révolution qui est de
beyrouth quoi vous paraît que la
sécurité des français ne plus assurer la
main à nos concurrents
voilà bien plus vite possible pour
remonter en ce sens avant justement les
enfants sur la panique
le pagne complète la famille complète
justement on a galéré pour avoir des
billets d'avion parce que on ne savait
pas du tout si on pouvait partie on ne
les 30 derniers billets d'avion délivré
par la cac
chez chantal goya qui fermait cetim
juillet d'une faillite imminente on
arrête de en arrête de on arrête de
travailler parce que l'armée va quand le
contrôle du du bâtiment de la cac et le
lendemain on pouvait plus rentrer dans
le périmètre est tout à l'heure à
l'assemblée roland dumas le ministre
français des affaires étrangères a
annoncé que la france mettait tout en
place pour rapatrier la plupart de ces
500 ressortissants encore présent à
pékin
barry a d'autre part décidé la réduction
de sa représentation diplomatique en
chine au minimum indispensable
et puis surtout ces événements
dramatiques une question majeure
où sont passés les dirigeants chinois
qui gouvernent maintenant un milliard
deux cents millions d'habitants il y a
encore un pouvoir c'est sûr on a appris
aujourd'hui par exemple que le parti
communiste l exclure tous ses membres
impliqués dans les troubles
une rumeur non confirmée annoncer
d'autres parcs qui à auchy aurait
remplacé le numéro un du parti
yahoo viande alors si vous voulez bien
tentons de savoir où en sont les
dirigeants chinois
michel mon comté avant la révolte des
étudiants le pouvoir en chine étaient
incarnés par quatre hommes
en première ligne le numéro un chinois
deng xiaoping
il n'est plus apparu devant une caméra
depuis sa rencontre avec gorbatchev il y
a quinze jours
certaines rumeurs le disent morts
d'autres annonces son hospitalisation
mais à shanghai pas à pékin la radio
chinoise on parle pas li peng ensuite le
premier ministre aille par les étudiants
c'est lui qui a décrété la loi martiale
il ya 13 jours
c'était sa dernière apparition publique
une très protocolaire rencontre avec des
ambassadeurs africains jan chan comme
chef de la commission militaire mais
surtout président de la république on le
dit par sa famille très liée au
commandement de la 27ème armée celle là
même qui a signé le massacre de la place
tiananmen zhao zhiang enfin le bien aimé
des étudiants ici avec eux sur cette
place il y a dix
jour il serait depuis lors emprisonné
dans un asile psychiatrique lui seul se
seraient opposés à l'intervention de
l'armée chinoise sur la foule des
étudiants il en paye peut-être
aujourd'hui le prix pour sa contestation
tous les diplomates internationaux sont
penchés au chevet de la chine en ce
moment les convulsions de ce pays
intrigue mais aussi inquiet par exemple
certaines sources médicales parle
maintenant de 7000 morts au cours des
affrontements du week-end dernier de la
répression de ces derniers jours en
exclusivité pour antenne de henry
kissinger a accepté de répondre aux
questions de notre chaîne l'ancien
secrétaire d'état américain qui continue
de faire autorité en matière de
politique internationale se dit et si
milite sur la chine
hilali à christine ockrent tout au plus
à votre avis après 40 ans de communisme
en chine est ce qu'il ya un système
politique de rechange et de méthodes
propres veines des points de la colonne
le président bush a suspendu les
contrats militaires le gouvernement
français a gelé ses relations avec la
chine
qu'est ce que l'occident pourrait
devrait faire le plus de mal avec cette
interview de henry kissinger nous
refermons pour ce soir le dossier
chinois le reste de l'actualité
maintenant avec d'abord une confirmation
à moscou les soviétiques veulent réduire
de moitié leur budget militaire du sis à
95 en six ans seulement
c'est ce qu'a annoncé tout à l'heure le
premier ministre nicolaï ricol et puis
la pologne
l'incroyable échange de politesses entre
solidarité et pouvoir communiste
l'opposition et le parti se concertent
pour accélérer le cours des réformes
démocratiques en pologne
reste à savoir quelle pourrait être la
participation de solidarité au
gouvernement
jacques merino et notre envoyé spécial à
varsovie
que faire d'une telle victoire est
évidemment la question à laquelle sur y
en a je trouvais très rapidement une
réponse réponse difficile à formuler
d'abord parce qu'il n'y a pas de
précédent historique
et puis ensuite parce que depuis sa
défaite le pouvoir ne cesse de harceler
solidarnosc sur le thème vous avez gagné
alors venez avec nous conduire les
affaires du pays le porte-parole du
gouvernement monsieur jase urban a même
laissé entendre cet après midi que le
gouvernement éventuellement pourraient
complètement laissé la place à celui
d'un match mais monsieur j'ai un urban
s'est très vite repris et introduit
quelques nuances
je parle seulement de différentes
possibilités qui sont actuellement des
batteries
je pense quoi qu'il arrive à l'issue de
ces élections sera celui d'un âge aura
une grande influence à société que celui
d'anne auch doit prendre sa part de
responsabilité
il s'agit des responsabilités dans
l'état dans l'économie
je n'ai déjà pas si mal besson doit
réfléchir sur les formes de cette
responsabilité et en débattre est ce que
le groupe un jour peut envisager d'être
dans l'opposition
il est aujourd'hui permis d'envisager
une telle situation
personnellement je trouverais cela assez
attrayant et même temps payant attrayant
parce que du point de vue politique ce
serait une situation nouvelle est
intéressante c'est plus agréable des
critiques et de revendiquer plutôt que
de décider et d'assumer ses
responsabilités et bien sûr le poulpe
dont parlait jacques merlino c'est le
parti ouvrier unifié polonais c'est à
dire le parti communiste polonais
d'autres informations internationales
tout de suite avec isabelle de lyon est
bien sûr d'abord l'iran qui continuent
de célébrer la mémoire de l'imam
khomeiny alors que la vie reprend son
cours à téhéran
c'est des mots ni officielle à la
mémoire de l'imam khomeiny avec les plus
grands dignitaires du
réunis autour d'alain dramani successeur
désigné de l'imam défunt ils ont lancé
un appel à l'unité autour du nouveau
guide de l'iran la foule a repris en
coeur des slogans contre les états unis
et israël
désigné par le testament de khomeiny
comme les ennemis de l'iran un testament
diffusé hier soir à la télévision
l'imam souhaitait que le président soit
issu d'une classe qui a connu les
privations
d'autre part radio téhéran a annoncé
aujourd'hui que les mouvements de foule
pendant les funérailles ont causé la
mort de plusieurs fidèles en tout près
de onze mille personnes ont été blessées
plus de 60 morts dont un grand nombre de
femmes et d'enfants 600 blessés c'est le
bilan d'affrontements interethniques
dans la république soviétique
d'ouzbékistan
depuis samedi les ouzbeks soboth
violemment à la minorité des tuques
mèche car selon l'agent stahl les
autorités locales en perdre le contrôle
de la situation malgré le couvre-feu et
l'envoi de 12 mille soldats la plupart
des victimes sont des kurdes
devant le congrès des députés du peuple
michail gorbatchev s'est dit préoccupé
il a lancé un nouvel appel au talent
crash d'un avion de ligne près de
paramaribo surinam
pour des raisons encore inconnues un
dc-8 en contenance amsterdam s'est
écrasé il y aurait plus de 160 morts
parmi les victimes plusieurs
footballeurs professionnels d'ascendance
surinamienne et qui jouait dans des
clubs de première division aux pays-bas
bac philo pour près de 500 mille
candidats un chiffre record une
curiosité cette année presque partout il
y a eu des sujets très lié à l'actualité
par exemple la révolte
peut-elle être un droit on peut
peut-être demander au peuple chinois
autre exemple une violence légale est
elle une violence là on peut peut-être
demander aux militaires chinois dernier
exemple que signifie l'expression la
force des faibles
eh bien cette fois chantal kimmerlin a
demandé la réponse aux lycéens de carlao
il son plancher de 8 heures à midi sur
des sujets différents sur toute la
france
mais tous de haut niveau pour les 820
candidats de ce lycée parisien
le sujet le plus choisi que signifie
l'expression la force des faibles
un devoir difficile ponctuée par la
seule présence angoissante de la montre
tous les sujets de philosophie de
dissertation sont toujours détenus la
garde de près difficile mais là pour
sévices et des demandes des
connaissances
sont difficiles mais qu ont-ils pu
écrire et développé en quatre pages et
trois parties sur la force des faibles
allez savoir j'ai défini la force d'une
manière générale ensuite la faiblesse
j'ai eu une nuit les deux en éclairant
par différents philosophes comme
nietzsche ou hegel et ensuite j'ai
essayé de conclure la meilleure façon
possible
ouais j'ai parlé de la mort de de
communiquer avec les religions et j'ai
montré que les faibles pouvaient avoir
une certaine pression quand on voit le
déchaînement de la foule qui a eu
pendant l'enterrement alors de donner
des exemples est une très bonne idée
mais l'important comme toujours dans une
dissertation de philosophie c'est que
ces exemples viennent appuyer en fait
des analyses ou une réflexion théorique
autres académies autres thèmes parmi les
plus séduisants tout-petits s'acheter
être libre consiste-t-il à se suffire à
soi même
quant à la liberté les candidats au bac
en or on peut les jours à venir
prochain rendez vous toutes disciplines
confondues du 19 au 23 juin
oui j'ajoute une information à ce sujet
à propos du bac sachez qu'en composant
sur votre minitel 36 15 codes apos vous
le faire tout de suite
vous aurez les réponses à tous les
sujets posée au bac philo ce matin et
pendant que les lycéens plancher les
députés faisait de même mais en fin
d'après midi
lionel jospin ouvrait le débat à
l'assemblée sur la loi d'orientation
son projet prévoit de transformer le
système éducatif mais il la vit dans un
esprit très concentré
dary boutboul est ressorti libre tout à
l'heure de l'hôtel de police de rouen
mais sa mère reste en garde à vue les
deux femmes sont ou étaient entendus à
propos du meurtre commis au havre
l'année dernière il pourrait être ce
meurtre lié à l'assassinât de jacques
perron le mari de la femme jockey henry
bodiguel c'est par une porte dérobée
située derrière l'hôtel de police de
rouen que davie boutboul a été libéré
dans le
courant de la journée en revanche sa
mère marie élisabeth compte-gouttes bull
est toujours en garde à vue à l'hôtel de
police où elle a été interrogée pendant
toute la journée par les policiers du
srpj et peut-être aussi mais ça reste à
confirmer par le juge michel beaulier du
havre
autres informations recueillies il y à
moins d'une heure et dont on est sûr
madame marie élisabeth con ce coup de
boule sera transférée dès demain au
havre où elle sera présentée au juge
boullier dès 7h30 du matin
mais cette affaire qu'on croyait
circonscrite entre paris rouen et le
havre a eu deux autres prolongements au
cours de la journée
annecy d'abord où un agent d'assurances
dont l'identité n'a pas été révélée
aurait servi d'intermédiaire dans des
transactions financières entre madame 11
groupe bull et monsieur bruno d'aspac le
représentant de commerce assassiné il ya
un an wavre et puis ensuite à paris où
une commerçante une charcutière à l eau
ce qui était placé en garde à vue
c'est de son magasin pour le téléphone
avait été placée sur table dès coûte que
madame compte-gouttes bull aurait passé
tous ses coups de gueule concernant
cette affaire
autre affaire qui ressurgit la sphère
pechiney aujourd'hui et ces jours ci
sont entendus les deux principaux
protagonistes de la faire
les frères trabelsi est aussi alain
boublil l'ancien chef de cabinet du
ministre des finances
car chagall et hervé brusini il y a
d'abord eu son frère nadir et puis lui
samir traboulsi 8 heures d'audition pour
un questionnaire en forme d'entonnoir
parce qu'il est difficile d'obtenir des
réponses claires disent les enquêteurs
l'homme d'affaires libanais affirme lui
que s'il est resté aussi longtemps dans
le bureau du juge c'est pascal minguet
principales questions posées à l'homme
d'affaires libanais la nature de ses
relations avec la société suisse au co
financé par l'intermédiaire de cette
société que 90 titres américains ont été
acquis avant le rachat d'american cannes
par péchiney des achats qui ont suivi de
très près chaque étape de la négociation
d'août à novembre 88 parmi les
actionnaires de ce co financent charbel
ghanem est un ami de longue date de
samir traboulsi un premier indice donc
pour le juge plus troublant ses coups de
téléphone passés à souk aux finances par
samir traboulsi du grand hôtel new
yorkais waldorf astoria et cela
en pleine affaire pechiney oui mais j'ai
téléphoné avant après et pendant nous a
rétorqué samir traboulsi autres indices
possibles pour le juge un document
retrouvé selon paris match au domicile
de roger patrice pelât l'année acheteurs
français aujourd'hui décédé un document
sur lequel figurerait le nom de samir
traboulsi en bonne place sur une liste
de relations d'affaires
aujourd'hui c'était au tour d'alain
boublil de comparaître devant le juge
d'oise est l'ancien directeur de cabinet
du ministre des finances affirme lui
qu'il n'a pas toujours été tenu informé
des négociations
par exemple le prix de vente du titre
triangle il ne leur est connue qu'au
dernier moment
dernier point à éclaircir les propos
échangés par alain boublil samir
traboulsi et patrice colas lors d'une
réception offerte par pierre bérégovoy
dans ce restaurant
de quoi at on bien pu parler une semaine
juste avant l'accord final la politique
maintenant les élections européennes
auront lieu dans une semaine et demi
maintenant les leaders sont en campagne
les sondages se multiplient ils sont
parfois d'ailleurs contradictoires en
tout cas tous les leaders se démène et
il y à des faveurs s'arrachent les
réformateurs de l'opposition sont très
courtisés
simone veil pub de liste des centristes
a rencontré trois d'entre eux alfie et
en savoie véronique saint olive une
journée placée sous le sceau de
l'environnement une occasion pour simone
veil de décliner fine mouche
la pureté des eaux et des forêts mais
aussi celle des coeurs voilà pourquoi
elle avait choisi ronald le berceau de
la rénovation
entre eux ils appellent mamie rénova et
qu'après novateur du cru barnier karine
et ombres sont bayrou ont accueilli
simone veil avec chaleur ils ont écouté
plaidé sa différence avec satisfaction
si on est socialiste nous n'acceptons
pas la politicienne
oui idéologie qu'ils abordent ces
questions mais en même temps nous
souhaitons donc longue liste en discuter
au fond ces questions que l'on recherche
des solutions de justice les solutions
de progrès à waziers qui passerait par
là a déclaré sa flamme à simone veil est
à saluer ce qu'il a appelé son combat
exemplaire
les rénovateurs ont entamé une délicate
partie de cache cache avec leurs partis
respectifs
les succès de leur projet d'autonomie et
lie au score que fera la liste sentry
simone veil elle ne recule devant rien
au nom de l'europe elle parle elle
explique elle discute jusqu'à emporter
l'adhésion final les entreprises
françaises partent à l'attack elles font
parler d'elle et elle se place dans la
hiérarchie mondiale fait bon signe deux
exemples lafarge copé une entreprise du
secteur du ciment est devenu le numéro
deux mondial dans ce secteur en
rachetant holding suisse et un groupe
espagnol
et puis autre exemple le groupe b est
celle qui vient de racheter une partie
de l'américain nabisco alain doublet qui
détaille et tout cela avec d'autres
informations économiques 17 milliards de
francs c'est la somme que devoir
rassembler antoine riboud le pdg de bsn
pour acheter les cinq filiales
européennes de l'américain nabisco psn
c'est entre autres gervais danone evian
puis sa mort à cronenbourg panzani mais
aussi biscuits vu van damme ou
l'alsacienne or nabisco s'est play en
france
balzers en allemagne walker en grande
bretagne si ou en italie donc la porte
d'entrée de bsn pour l'europe 2
milliards et luc dollars le plus gros
achat français jamais réalisée à
l'étranger
où l'on reparle de max théret le
ministre des finances vu refuser
l'autorisation de rachat de pathé cinéma
par son groupe italo suisse max théret
investissement la loi française
concernant les capitaux étrangers
n'auraient pas été respectées max théret
avait racheté pathé cinéma 950 millions
d'euros groupes rivaux et suez en
janvier dernier
146 mesures pour faciliter la vie des
chômeurs parmi les mesures adoptées en
conseil des ministres amélioration de
l'accueil dans les services publics
téléphone machine à écrire journaux
aident à la recherche d'un emploi bras
l'édition d'un guide les droits du
chômeur versement d'indemnités transport
avant les démarches protection sociale
égale à des actifs sensibilisation de
l'opinion publique au problème des
chômeurs
roland garros de tous les dangers chaque
match est une véritable partie de poker
dernier gagnant date l'américain michael
chang celui là même qui est éliminé il
vendrait d'un avant-hier chance cette
fois a éliminé en quarts de finale grâce
à dieu et en quatre sets
l'haïtien âge nord jeudi grâce à dieu
parce que ces chambres lui-même qui a vu
dans sa victoire l'action du tout
puissant alors déjà que dieu à se
préoccuper du sort d'un milliard de
chinois
en plus ils l'aident l'immigré américain
change sur le central de roland garros
et puis j'ai en ma mère je me tourne
vers vous car la sensation de la soirée
fin de la fin d'après midi c'est
l'élimination de wilander si l'on résume
c'est simple les trois derniers
vainqueurs du tournoi de roland garros
sont sortis c'est à dire noir l'indl et
vilander ajouté parmi les surprises
agassi et vous avez le roland garros 89
de toutes les surprises
mats wilander éliminé en trois sets le
tenant du titre parents joueurs qu'il
est même à tête de série 2 soviétique
andreï chesnokov 3,7 pour une partie de
trois heures avec des échanges
interminables surtout dans le troisième
set le seul d'ailleurs dans lequel vit
lambert s'est montré digne de son niveau
inexistant durant les deux premiers et
la même encaissé un cinglant 6 0 dans le
deuxième wilander a eu trois balles de
set dans la troisième manche mais n'a
pas su en profiter
c'est un roland garros révolution
ok nous assistons chez stock of en demi
finale il est le deuxième se d'éthique
après m'être aignan 72 à atteindre ce
niveau de la compétition
allez on optionnaires je vous vois venir
mon cher jean il vous parlais j'imagine
de l'américain chambre tian qui sera
l'autre demi finalistes puisque il sera
non seulement le demi-finaliste en plus
le plus jeune demi finaliste de
l'histoire de roland garros
il a 17 ans et il était opposé cet après
midi vous l'avais dit à l'haïtien agenor
chante cette fois est content d'avoir
battu agenor maman de change elle aussi
elle respire et elle ce même il est même
allé à quelques embrassades le public en
revanche a moins apprécié aujourd'hui
les coups de bluff de chambre même si le
résultat est le même double faute sur le
service d'un génome agenor pleite mais
qui n'a pas vraiment su comment
contourner le jeu très gênant de ce
jeune zhang résultats c'est donc jean
qui va jouer les demi finales de roland
garros alors hervé demain ce sera au
tour des féminines
en lice pour leur demi-finale on se
retrouve donc demain soir merci jean à
demain effectivement on se retrouve
demain soir très vite en cycliste
laurent fignon toujours maillot rose du
giro
aujourd'hui c'était une étape contre la
montre elle a été gagnée par le
colombien herrera laurent fignon garde
donc le maillot rose avec pas grand
chose une sève d' avance sur huit pony
et une vingt-et-une surprendre ce thème
ce sera dur mais c'est jouable
voici laurent fignon et son beau maillot
rose alors chang invoque le ciel les
gaulois redouté qu'il ne leur tombe sur
la tête mais ceux qui étaient au salon
du bourget aujourd'hui ont eu du mal à
en croire leurs yeux certains ont dû
penser qu'il s'agissait de venir et bien
regardez cette image étonnante
c'est ce matin à paris la navette
soviétique bouran qui est arrivé
accroché sur le dos de l'antonov 225 e
plus gros avion du monde 400 tonnes à
l'atterrissage
etonnant non et les deux monstres blanc
été rejoints cet après-midi par la
silhouette noire de l'avion espion
américain
le fr 71 sél avion le plus rapide du
monde
il vole écoutez bien à 3500 km heure
c'est lui aussi une belle villa park
voit la fin du journal météo tout de
suite c'est petit c'est laurent cabrol
avec un beau pull à jacquard de couleurs
n'oubliez pas
morceaux choisis tout à l'heure à 22h15
l'émission de christian qui décèle
résumé de roland garros dernier journal
henri sannier 23h30 et puis demain télé
télé matin 6h30 comme d'habitude
excellente soirée sur antenne 2 à demain
20 heures